my name is Roland Schwartz I'm a
computational biologist at the European
bioinformatics Institute
the major part of my research is the
development of new statistical
approaches and computational methods for
improving what is called phylogenetic
inference the reconstruction of the Tree
of Life or parts of the Tree of Life one
of the most fascinating things about DNA
for me is that it's digital and consists
of these four characters a C's T's and
G's so it lends itself to the analysis
with computational methods and we're
developing and improving those methods
that look in DNA sequences for these
changes so we can say in the course of
evolution from animal 1 to animal two a
one of these A's for example at a
certain position in the sequence has
evolved to AC I don't think there is
really a typical day in my work I think
it really depends on the project you're
working on so even though I'm a
computational biologists not all of my
time is spent in front of the computer I
think an important part of the projects
that I do are meeting the collaborators
talking to people to biologists to the
medics to try to understand their point
of view in their problems but also
withdrawing in a quiet corner to read
some papers and try to get your head
around a certain project and problem
before you return to the computer and
try to analyze the data and so on one of
the greatest things about my line of
work I think is how interdisciplinary it
is so apart from our own line of
research I work with both biologists
with clinical scientists and every time
I help them analyze their data help them
solve their problems I myself learn a
lot of new biology as well as a lot of
new computer science and maths
I believe that careers are the sort of
evolutionary processes in the same sense
that random changes on the genome occur
and give rise to all these new organisms
I think it has been random changes in my
life that have made me first go into
bioinformatics and then later end up
here at the EBI in Cambridge and so
while I believe that you should have a
rough idea of where you're going
think you cannot prepare for the
completely unknown if I remember back in
my days in school while I enjoy certain
subjects of course I always thought that
learning was usual earned for your
parents or for your teachers or to have
good grades but then later when I
started doing my PhD where exclusively
could focus on the actual research that
I was interested in suddenly I found it
really exciting to learn new things and
I think that's one of the most rewarding
things you can have in your job is to
get paid for learning